you to want sex quizy aujourd'hui on se
retrouve pour un nouvel épisode max
payne
donc je rappelle la dernière fois max
payne octave est pas réussi à retrouver
la fille de rodrigo donc au final il est
revenu le voir et puis sont fait
attaquer dans son entreprise dans son
espèce d'entrepôts donc malheureusement
rodrigo est morte ou moins des morts
sauf max payne max payne a ensuite
décidé de se raser le crâne et là on
attaque le disque de quoi voir qu'est-ce
qui va faire comment il va essayer de
retrouver fabien dallas fille de rodrigo
donc c'est parti on découvre ça tout de
suite juste là j'ai loupé quatre
secondes de gameplay dont qui on a juste
vu qu'il appelait quelqu'un puis bah là
il appelle justement eu bat donc on est
encore en compagnie de jeunes alias
pascal tailleux alias c'est tout c'est
parti max a séduit 3 morts read and go
une au 10 mars +63 back to the max en
femme lesbienne trop la parade
voyez donc finalement retour on retourne
à la chasse à la fabiana retour monde
alors effectivement il y avait eu un bug
en fait eu un écran noir c'était pas
prévu on a relancé un peu nettes au
disque est relancé et puis là par mois
il yal'image cette fois
voilà d'accord voyage couperet l'écran
noir montage je pense à moins que ça va
faire quoi wells et tu loupes ce moment
il y avait deux cas des dieux d'accord
ok bon ben je comprends leur montage en
fait j'adore que mon jeu vidéo ça fait
plus beau jour de juin
m
c'est à la casse déserte à face à l'arc
quand tu perds contre le chômage comme
igor propos qui vous s'était dit à tous
exilés perdirent d argent et passe à qui
la prend goût à grand gaube à [ __ ]
c'est ma petite voix alors on se trouve
donc dans un mauvais jour
quand j'étais encore dans le caniveau
c'est pas fou va monter
je m'attendais pas du tout à son honneur
le maire de croix
alors juste le goût
pas besoin de sur le côté quoi
bon alors une porte je prends mon sac
boîte de nuit
je ne crois pas d'école ténue
tahar et d'enjeux ya toujours des
drogues sexe violence mais trop tard les
vaincus mais tous ne voyez pas futile de
bois d'acier
merde merde je bosse fils qui s'est
passé bon on a dû se faire attaquer
amélie senna et ils sont bons
voyage 3 4 matic et un quart est ok bon
c'est pas tout bar
c'est bon
voilà partie nord-est et un appel à ces
matinales voilà là bas un pop up
pourquoi ta merde encore frappé on
remarque quoi franchement c'est pas plus
mal si à un moment où ces masques
expressifs sic mais du coup on sait pas
ce qui s'est passé ça fait chier free
kids d'avoir un truc ici si surya
antalgiques le coût du connacht
il a un canon scié à l'ap antalgiques
pas j'aurais été sur l ego au
ça fait mal mais je suis poli
au tlm en salle ouais je regarde attend
juste prendre ça au parfum de voir voilà
et bata faut situer stratégie qui parle
ces deux là on vient là on n'a pas de
pot choix
comme par hasard c'est désert
non à la c2a a pourtant des équipes
d'aso nord bon je ne vois pas chérie je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé du cosim
stress ou pousser chier bonnel
la compagnie il nous semble
oui
tout autour en plus ils ont intérêt à
faire gaffe sont sur les toits en fait
une accolade
et
toutes les chances et du coup je peux
pas récupérer d'armes non
je sens j'ai crevé
j'ai pas pourquoi
abella est là il faut branche r je vais
quand même prendre cher
regardez c'est quoi c'est la petite
gueule que j'ai moi
anelka
parti je crois que manger pour en sortir
avec sylvie il ya des chiens
elle sait faire
waouh
ok
son style
en ville mal est fait
ils valent aussi faut aller au
maintenant bah voilà
en quelques mois
je suis black manière je te laisse les
preuves
wahaha elle vaut une petite halte aux
remontées par ici
je suis fort à faire puisque j'en suis
un
à
wallace a pas tardé la formation
antalgiques
je n'ai toujours pas la peine allez brut
chien je déteste ça quand je te prends
mais c'est ma plus grosse vie what u
voilà si je veux tu imagines art et sa
taille ne peut pas descendre son arme
qua non mais super c'est débile pas
baisser son âme ce connard [ __ ] non
mais jacques ans [ __ ] je recommence de
lagrasse super
tout ça parce que ce déluge n'est pas
baisser son armée d'accord ok ok c'est
le sage est seul tout ça parce qu'il n'a
pas baissé son arbre réussi
je tais toi
on
voilà c'est le guen plutôt pas
bakayoko voilà ça c'est fait et continue
encore là bas et puis un petit bourg
hamas a failli a pas de chien et deux en
autres
aimar aussi c'est un état qu'est-ce que
j'ai commun et à pour faire le sale tour
à mers les lapins oies
ils ont changé de place n'était pas la
rage
tahar endroit qui est un bel de kito
ah ah hu à lattes et pérols situons
lever qu'un débat dans les gens c'est
alors qu'il en a tu leur mets 36 balle
dans le cou à martha
c'est à cause de toi la quiche immortal
heures un petit [ __ ]
hu ancien c'est joli comme un outil
parfait par fait alors on va ramasser ça
se sent tellement pas mais j'ai pas pris
ce qui arrivé en bas mais en forte
baisse
j'ai raconté ce qu'il y ait quelqu'un
la crise